one week from tonight we will find out
where this man will be playing his
professional football at the 2019 NFL
Draft he is from the University of
Michigan born and raised in Plainfield
New Jersey just up the road from where I
grew up in Staten Island New York he is
none other than rashon Gary good to see
you sir good to see so where do you
think you're going do you have an idea
do you have any sense right now I wish I
wish but uh you know there's been going
through the process enjoying it and um
we know teams I'm filling them they're
filling me so i'ma see who calls my
phone Thursday next Thursday and are you
gonna be in Nashville or you're gonna be
somewhere I'm gonna be in in Arbor a
little get-together in Ann Arbor
whatever role we're going rebel roll
okay a bowling alley so bowling alley
yeah would you choose a bowling alley
just because it's gonna be is gonna be
you know achievement in my life and um
you know just having everybody around me
that made me the man I am today you
don't want to fill it off the field and
just getting a bye together you so I get
that phone call if we go bowling
you're gonna go wall you're gonna roll
some a little bit all right what's your
game give me games you rusty and rusty
but you know every time I get it I try
to go for the strike have you have you
rolled a 300 if you're gonna never never
never I'm new to this I'm China you know
come over new hobby store
just seeing a bowling ball in your hand
might look like a marble I'm a TV go and
see it just to see what that's like okay
any of your teammates gonna be there
other people gonna be there who's still
working that out right now but you know
the family's gonna be in a building so
we're gonna come in by 30 deep in have
some too good time and go roll roll 30
deep and roll okay roll 10 frames who
have you visited with yeah my Benton
the Jets Jaguars bingos Giants Lions
Seahawks Oakland and met with a couple
of teams so okay so you visited
literally physically visited those
places or you've been all over the
country what look obviously you want to
go wherever you want to go you want to
go as high as you want to go what would
it mean for you to be drafted by the
Jets of the Giants being from Plainfield
New Jersey
rashon yeah you know just being drafted
period is an honor but you know what the
Jets and Giants is you
me being from Jersey is a little
prideful you know when you win there
means more you know to the state you
know where I grew up in you know to the
people around it have you spoken on
peppers at all a little bit a little bit
going through this process you know
going through the combine but as
recently no okay cuz now he's you know
he's he's mr. New Jersey by way of
Michigan now with the Giants right now
so I'm just kind of just poking around
right here and that in terms of the
combine there's a stat the fastest
40-yard dash among all players to weigh
275 pounds or more since the official
combine results were tracked in 2003
four point five eight is that the
fastest you can run no I got a got a
extra couple gears next couple gears
more you know if I run it again imma
tell anybody I for four so I believe in
myself and I know my capability so I
know I got a little bit more a little
bit more in the tank it's a little bit
what do you think of pre-snap what goes
through your mind man um number one
reading the keys um you know first of
all starting off from down a distance
and um you know after that offer a
personnel 11 12 13 and um no seeing what
he got in the game and if the Titans up
or if he's coming to motion things like
that so but I've other than that I'm
just ready for the ball to snaps I could
put my hands on somebody well as you
know you know I was at the combine you
were too it was just remarkable the
number of talented players at your
position that there are what what
separates you in your mind from
everybody else oh yeah number one my
versatility
um you know I could play everything I'm
a defensive end but I'm able to get
doing it going to the three taking uh
rush about the edge um you know driving
to the curl drop it to the flat so I'm
very versatile demand I'm I feel like
I'm everything a team needs okay let's
talk about coach Harbaugh let's talk
about Jim yeah when do you first meet
him met him I want to say my junior high
school mm-hmm junior high school know he
just got the job at Michigan and uh just
talking to him he's a great man um you
know coming for the 49ers and you know
being an NFL coach you know he played a
good factor in me going to Michigan on
me put Michigan program an organization
where you know it's ran a certain way
and um you gotta follow the rules and
you
you gonna achieve your dreams so coach
Harbaugh is a guy with a plan and all I
gotta do is listen to him executed well
have you what's the what's the craziest
thing you've heard out of his mouth the
craziest oh no man it's really hard to
say he's a different type of guy so I
love the guy so you know we're we're in
good company here the idea that you
don't eat chicken because it's a nervous
bird would you agree with that oh yeah
absolutely that comes out of life game
is never served so now he believes in it
there's never served no pie after
practice but Torres game bankers dinner
because it's a nervous bird yes sir
okay when a certain someone came in 2016
I'm gonna go there down their throat
again when I asked this question of
Devin Bush and I stepped in it but I was
gonna get in the same way certain
someone came to speak to the team in
2016 before the game how how aroused
were you by that former University of
Michigan person coming to speak to the
team um you know the honor um you know
having people come back not people but
Michigan men come back home you know
showed a passion for the program and you
know just believing in us um you know
Michigan men's all around the world you
know the alumni is great so it's being
able to have a person come back you know
show the love and passion just makes you
want to place not even harder do you
know who I'm talking about
I would assume so who is it who's that
person I'm talking about I'm looking at
him fantastic I said it Devon Bushies
like it was great having Brady there
like no no that's not what that was
that was great it was great yeah by the
way I think it went I think it went
Jeter me and then Brady yeah they kind
of got lost in that shuffle Jeter before
Brady yeah was Jeter and then me and
then Brady didn't Jeter Jeter came at
you did he did but terms of like talking
to the team yeah I gotta say Tom Brady
then you is only very well she's cuz I
haven't one of these any I'm haven't won
any Emmys either so it's just I've been
nominated it's like being nominee not
take him away from you okay so was like
it made you want to go hit somebody
against UCF that'd be after hear me
thank you that's what I'm looking for
there maybe you're not there is an
iron-rich and Eisen there's no doubt
about it
rashon Gary here on the Rich Eisen show
you also are the only one in the draft
who started your own sports agency
founder and CEO of rashon Gary sports
why did you do that what's your
motivation the number one reason get my
family a better life my mom my sister my
two nephews they've been my motivation
you know ever since I started playing
football you know he knows he's growing
up and know everything my mom dad my
sister did raise me to be the man I am
today so you know there's putting that
together and just always my love for the
game you know I'm you know even days
when after I hang up my cleats I always
want to be around a game and that's just
a good way to do that right so you're
representing yourself is essentially
what you're doing or you have others who
are they're gonna be part of rashon gary
sports that represent you yes part of
this others that's in the organization
that represents me so I'm not my own
agent I actually have an agent right
okay so you're not just gonna come right
out of the gate as your own Jerry
Maguire at some point but at some point
is that something that you would aspire
to at some point is this a way to set
yourself up maybe for what's going on
after your playing career well yeah you
know who knows me I'm just you know
staying in the moment doing what I got
to do and uh number one focus on the
best football player I could be right
now so you know my mom's handle
everything I'd say that's her project
and okay I'm just focusing on football
all right and what's the strangest
question you were asked at the combine
with Sean strangers
Oh would you get asked that it might be
that there's like what's going on
strangers to be honest like my combine
experience and my drive faster
been pretty smooth okay constantly did
you know the same questions did you get
in the staring contest with Seattle no
they didn't it wouldn't dare do the
staring contest with you
yeah no not at all to have that he's not
amazing Christmas Devin Bush said he did
now and then again why do I keep
blanking on the young man who is the
cornerback who is the first to say it
but
so I guess corners and linebackers
they're doing staring contests but not
you
yeah no no how would you do in a staring
contest you know in that type of a
circumstance I come out on top
Lonnie Johnson right Lonnie Johnson
Lonnie come out on top
okay I would do it right now but I don't
want to get into all that right now with
you yeah when you sat out the Peach Bowl
against Florida to prepare for the draft
it was you Curran Higdon and how tough
was that to to tell hardball this is
what you were gonna do yet I was you
know with my decisions throughout my
life that's probably one of the hardest
ones I had to you know come up with you
know send down my family you know you
know coming up to a conclusion and then
you know taking it to you know hardball
and Dan coach Broncos Madison and just
you know I was crying um you know three
years I Michigan I let everything out on
the field for my brothers my coaches you
know the fans and everything so
Michigan's always gonna be a part of me
and just you know having that decision
you know being made and going to coach
Harbaugh and having him you know agree
with me so you know what I made it
better but you know leaving a team and I
know to pursue your dreams and you know
making the best decision for you it was
always hard
he said he agreed with you yes sir and
did anybody bring this up to you at the
combine under the concept of you may be
leaving your teammates behind cuz that's
what a lot of NFL evaluators sometimes
might view that's there's some
evaluators that frown upon that I'm not
one of them just I'm not an evaluator
I'm not saying that but I'm just asking
you that it's a sort of a devil's
advocate here oh yeah no definitely I
understand but uh you know going through
the combine and asking question is just
more of a you know what was your thought
process and why you did that slow you
know just going through a process like I
just beyond is any no say what it is
okay let's show it right here with Sean
on the screen I'll describe it to the
radio audience this is the worst part of
the samel camp for me and my run rich
run was when they actually had all the
michigan guys come run right straight
through me right there now it looks like
rashon you we're all chasing Devin Bush
but it does look like you get win of
it's right here
of course what do you mean of course
chase no faster now he does of course
does Devin know that you could have run
faster do you think Devin no I feel like
anybody who knows me know I like to
compete so if I get another crack at it
I'm gonna make sure okay yeah I do what
I gotta do okay were you on the field
prior to the Michigan State game - no no
it was a dozen when I said that was hard
for me that was one you know I was in my
apartment watched or not you were in the
apartment watching that's right what do
you think of when you saw Devon to tear
up the middle of the field with his with
his cleats that's just a game I wish I
was there for it um you know every time
you go play our little sister oh boy
little sister oh my gosh 2000 always the
type of passion and anger that you have
for that terrible game just seeing no my
brother got there with the emotions I
would've had times 100 you know it hurts
but you know we came out with the
winning we own Michigan period okay
by the way to lean into the microphone
yes so everybody know out there for you
stay fans University of Michigan
Wolverines that's our state period and
uh BCI next year well we'll see you in
the National Football League soon -
rishon Gary we'll see you soon - thanks
for coming on the show man I really
really appreciate it good luck to you
moving forward and not just with
football with everything else off the
field with Sean Gary sports and more and
go you know go roll next Thursday night
oh absolutely the only enjoy when we
come I'll call you up maybe in when when
you're in your new digs and we'll talk
about your your new setup yeah I look
for I look forward to that at rashon a
Gary on Twitter and Instagram as well
you're gonna have to the going up to the
NFL Network now yeah I'll tell Holly
tell everyone they're high for me
definitely yeah and I'll be with the NFL
Network next week - Thursday night for
draft night on the NFL Network and this
man rashon Gary he's going to find out
where
he's gonna go for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on BR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app